a mother Teresa to get up and say hey I
just won't let you know call that poor
kid that personality tell him to get out
get the hell out of here you know who do
you think you are it wouldn't fit
because it's not their personality Trump
has his name all over the place on
Brian's okay so the Charles Schwab so
the JP Morgan so that Morgan Stanley
so that Dean Witter so do many other
brands McClaren is someone's [ __ ] name
Ferrari is Enzo Ferraris name right I
mean I can give you all of these names
is someone's name so can you imagine if
you wanted to start a company you said
you're gonna name your company after
your name what a show-off many are such
a show-off you know how dare you come up
with a book and put your cover on top of
the book you're so insecure you're such
a show-off right okay so all that stuff
said and done typically when you work in
a company the person that comes up and
moves up faster is a person that is
gonna bring up the fact that they are
really making an effort and they're
making a case that I am working hard I'm
doing my part and this is why dot dot
dot okay
I encourage my guys at the Home Office
to always come up to me and ask me for
rails but I tell them how to ask me for
race right I mean if you got a real
reputation of coming up to me and asking
for race based on numbers and results
and all that other stuff well then I'll
sit down and consider it but I teach you
how to ask me for race I don't mind you
showing off I have one of our employees
that will sit down and she'll put
together a twenty page PowerPoint you
know what the first 19 pages are how
amazing she is and by the way I love
listening to it it doesn't bother me I
like it it doesn't sit there and for me
gone so you know what screw all this
other stuff no it doesn't bother me I'm
fine with it but now let me give you a
different side of showoff
let me give you a different side of
show-off showing off doesn't work when
you show off in a way that doesn't fit
your personality that's when you screw
up
let me explain to what I mean by this if
you if your style isn't like Trump and
you try to show off like Trump it
wouldn't work imagine if Trump says I'm
gonna try to show off like
mother Teresa do you realize how
confused he would be I mean the guy
would be so confused it would be insane
he would be absolutely insane he would
be absolutely insane if he showed off
like it I want you to think about
tomorrow Trump comes out and he says
something like this a good afternoon
American people I just wanted to speak
to all of you and let you know that I
love you so much and life is all about
love and I love the Democrats and
Hillary you know all this time I've been
thinking about it I just love Hillary
Clinton so much and my favorite person
if CNN CEO I just love CNN Ted Turner
and Anderson Cooper such a sweet guy
and we just need to love each other and
there's a meeting and he goes around
hugging every single one of the
congressmen and Senators that are
Democrats and Hillary Clinton's and he's
crying can you imagine that can you
imagine Trump doing that you would be
confused the same goes if we were to ask
you to say okay for a mother Teresa to
get up and say hey I just won't let you
know called I predict that personality
tell him to get out get the hell out of
here you know who do you think you are
it wouldn't fit because it's not their
personality it's their personality
that's when showing off doesn't work
years ago in 2002 when I got into the
financial service I got involved in 2001
in financial services but 2002 I got
involved in a different company a trans
America had a very good experience but I
went there and there was this guy
there's this one guy who got up and he
was speaking and I had no idea what this
guy was he was trying to copy another
guy's style of speaking it would walk
like him he was short you know he was
trying to speak just like this other guy
he was off the other guy was also short
this guy would try to walk up just like
him you know do everything like him and
I would sit down like I was branded of
2002 maybe I've been the business for a
couple months I said man it just doesn't
fit you you look so fake this is more
like my skin hurts listening to you I
can't even sit in you foot has that ever
happened to you sure that's a person
that's trying to show off like another
person and it doesn't work it only works
if it fits your personality so if you've
ever been listen if this is your style
and this is how you
behave if these two match
that's authenticity but if this is your
style okay let's just say this is your
style on how you are your personality or
character your style your DNA and you're
trying to act like somebody else
everybody feels it and it doesn't feel
authentic so what does this mean
you got to figure out what fits you it
doesn't matter what you're doing what
fits your personality some people said
well path you know how do we speak the
way you do this is how I am since I was
a kid I told stories you know this is my
style